right Paul you become we would be called
the female Andrew Tate how do you plead
well I take it as a compliment you know
I'm a fan of Andrew Tate of everything
he says
um it depends what we're talking about
but overall I think he's got a good
message I think he's good for young men
okay look you're talking about women
predominantly uh which is why you've got
this big following and your view is that
modern feminism is deeply flawed I would
argue a lot of your proposals like
taking the vote away from a are deeply
regressive why would you want to remove
just from yourself the right to vote
well um what happened was I I had the
same view right
um back when I started I was like why I
found out that only five percent of
women wanted the right to vote and I
couldn't figure out like why would women
not no it's true
at the time it is they've been
conditioned by men to think that they
shouldn't have of them I mean that's
what they say but